Ukraine's potential membership
in NATO will also be top of mind
as President
Biden prepares to head overseas
for NATO's summit next week.
CNN's Fareed Zakaria
just sat down
with President Biden
for an exclusive interview
and asked him about Ukraine
wanting to join NATO's very much.
Take a listen.
When you go to the NATO summit,
the big strategic issue is that Ukraine
wants membership in NATO
should it get membership NATO.
I don't think it's
ready for membership in NATO's.
But here's the deal.
I spent,
as you know, a
great deal of time
trying to hold NATO's together
because I believe has had
an overwhelming objective
from the time we launched
285,000 troops in Ukraine.
And that was to break Naito.
He was confident in my view,
and many in the intelligence community
he was company could break narrow
to holding there together
is really critical.
I don't think there is unanimity
in NATO's
about whether or not to bring Ukraine
into the NATO's family.
Now, at this moment
in the middle of a war,
for example,
if you did that,
then, you know, we I
and I mean what I say,
we're determined
to commit
every inch of
territory that is NATO's territory.
It's a commitment that we've all made,
no matter what.
If the war is going
on, then we're all in the war.
You know, we're at war with Russia,
if that were the case.
So I think we have to lay out a path
for a rational path for Russia, for
you and me,
for Ukraine
to be able to qualify to get into Naito.
And we have when the very first time
I met with Putin
two years ago, in Geneva,
and he said,
I want commitments on no Ukraine
and NATO,
I said, we're not going to do that
because it's an open door policy.
We're not going to shut anybody out.
Naito is a process
that takes some time
to meet all the qualifications
and from democratization
to a whole range of other issues.
So in the meantime, though,
I've spoken with Zelensky
at length about this.
And one of the things I indicated is
the United States
would be ready
to provide
while the process was going on.
And it's going to take a while
while that process
is going on to provide security.
All the security
we provide for you, for Israel,
providing the weaponry
that needs the capacity
to defend themselves.
If there is an agreement,
if there is a cease fire,
if there is a peace agreement,
and so I think we can work it out.
And but I think it's premature
to say to call for a vote,
you know, in now
because there's other qualifications
to be reminded
clearly in democratization
and some of those issues.
You can see
all of Fareed's interview
with President Biden
this Sunday on Jeeps.
That airs at 10 a.m.
Eastern only on CNN.
Joining us now
to discuss,
a member of the House Foreign Affairs
Committee, New York
Republican Congressman Mike Lawlor.
Congressman, good to see you.
Thanks for joining us today.
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham for having me.
Lindsey Graham implied he wants Ukraine's
native membership to happen right away.
Lindsey
Graham says he's trying to get both sides
of the aisle,
Democrats and Republicans in the Senate,
to sign on to a resolution to urge
Naito to accept Ukraine
Would you sign onto such a thing
if it came before you in the House?
Well, it's certainly something that
will be under consideration.
We had a hearing just a few weeks ago
with administration officials
specifically I
and some of my colleagues
asked about
Ukraine's acceptance into NAITO
and whether or not the administration
would be pushing for that.
At the Naito Summit,
obviously,
we have our answer from the president.
He does not think they are ready for it.
I do think that the sooner
Ukraine joins Naito, the better.
Obviously, there is a process.
It does take time.
But I do think the administration
should be more forward leaning in pushing
for Ukraine's acceptance into naito.
I think at the end of the day here,
the president is right
insofar as Russia and Vladimir Putin
certainly thought
that they could break naito,
that we would not be unified
with our allies in response
to their illegal war
and invasion of Ukraine.
We have been unified.
We need to continue to be unified
and we need to ensure
that Ukraine
is able to defend its sovereignty.
And I have been very strong
in support of this
from the beginning
because Vladimir Putin is a vile thug
and dictator
and has no interest
in stopping at Ukraine.
And that much is clear.
So, look,
let's talk about the cluster bomb News
today that the Biden
administration, Biden administration
is going to provide
cluster bombs to Ukraine
even though the United States
has not banned cluster bombs.
But the U.S.
did begin
phasing out the use of cluster bombs
about seven or eight years ago
because of the potential danger
they pose to civilians,
because so many do not go off immediately
and also because of the widespread
explosion radius.
And though the Pentagon insists
that the so-called dud rate is low,
they still do pose risks to civilians
Do you think it's a good idea
Look, I
think obviously, as the president
alluded to, you know, the Ukrainian
military is running low on ammunition.
You've in the last few weeks seen
a breakdown between Vladimir Putin
and the Wagner group.
And so
I think the counteroffensive is critical
And we're at a critical stage
in this war
and for Ukraine's ability
to defend itself.
And so I think
getting them as much ammunition
and weaponry as possible
is critically important.
I think there's two key points to note.
Number one, obviously,
we are not party to any any agreement
on the use of cluster munitions.
But in addition to that,
these would be used
by Ukraine in defense of its sovereignty.
In its own borders as opposed to,
you know, bombing outside of its borders.
And I think that is a distinction
that is important to note.
They are trying
to defend their sovereignty
and they are at war
with Russia
and the Russian military and its forces.
So I think in this instance, given what
the use is intended for,
given the limited
chance of
it impacting civilian casualties,
I do think it is the right decision.
And I think
and I support
what the administration
is trying to do here.
All right.
Republican congressman
from New York, Mike Lawlor.
Thank you so much, sir.
Have a good weekend.